commenters on Twitter don't have many
nice things to say about Aquaman 2 after
recent test screenings so why are they
upset one of the film stars may have
something to do with it Hell hath no
fury like a comic book movie fan Scorn
the Slate of movies that make up DC
Comic sufferings have often been
divisive among General audiences and
purists alike movies like Green Lantern
Batman v Superman dawn of Justice and
Wonder Woman 1984 to name a few
certainly divided critics and fans upon
release this is probably why Warner
Brothers has such a problem emulating
the overwhelming success of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe no matter how hard
the studio tries of course DC also has
had its fair share of hits like the
original Aquaman Shazam and the HBO Max
show Peacemaker the first Aquaman made a
character that is derided in some
circles for his ability to talk to fish
into a Bonafide superhero accessible to
the public at large however the success
of Aquaman shouldn't be noted without
mentioning the charismatic performance
of Jason Momoa and the efforts of famous
director James Juan but with a
long-awaited sequel Aquaman and the lost
kingdom soon on the horizon it seems as
if DC is currently offering test
screenings for the movie to see how well
it will be received and it seems like
there may be some murky Waters ahead for
the king of Atlantis if the comments are
to be believed according to many who
have attended these early showings Mamoa
isn't the problem supporting actress
Amber Heard supposedly is according to
various social media commentators as
reported by De setso apparently Aquaman
in the lost kingdom is suffering from
poor test screenings with many saying
that they can't even finish the movie of
course this kind of information invokes
quite a strong response from some DC
fans mainly because of the
well-publicized issues and negative
furore surrounding Amber Heard who plays
Mira in the series this comes after the
public court drama between Heard and
Johnny Depp and some social media
commentators wasted no time levying the
supposed poor performance of Aquaman the
lost kingdom squarely unheard one person
wrote on Twitter if you've seen the
latest reviews for Aquaman 2 it's pretty
evident people don't take Amber
seriously anymore and simply no longer
want to see her on their screen others
also felt similar with another Twitter
user writing it should come as no
surprise that Aquaman 2 screenings are
bad Amber Heard cannot act she also has
no chemistry with the leading man no
film will prevail under those conditions
if anything these comments show that
many are quick to blame herd for any
issues surrounding Aquaman 2. it will be
interesting to see the overall public
perception when the movie finally
becomes available ever since Aquaman and
the lost kingdom was announced questions
pertaining to Amber heard's involvement
lingard with her personal issues result
in her being asked from the production
or has Warner Brothers ignored the Press
surrounding her maintaining the
pre-existing course well according to
herd herself the truth is a mix of both
evidently she hasn't been totally
removed from the Aquaman sequel but she
has claimed that her screen time has
been greatly reduced heard claims during
a May 2022 Court testimony I fought
really hard to stay in the movie they
didn't want to include me in the
objection your honor she goes on to
explain that his production ramped up
she received several scripts that would
change dramatically while this is far
from unheard of in the world of
entertainment heard notes that the
scenes removed were miracentric action
sequences signaling to her that Warner
Brothers wanted to minimize her presence
in the film as much as possible despite
Amber heard's claim it seems that Mira
is indeed still a big part of Aquaman
and the Lost Kingdom at least a big
enough part for those in attendance at
test screenings to take notice we'll
find out just how true or this is when
the film opens on December 25th 2023
foreign